foreign
welcome back to another video by simply
learn this is a new verb and in this
video we are going to create Instagram
clone using react.js but before we begin
if you haven't subscribed to our Channel
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and press the Bell icon so you
will never miss any update from Simply
learn so without further Ado let's begin
and see what's in it for you but first
let me tell you what react is so what is
react.js react is a JavaScript library
that is used to build mobile and web
applications fast and Interactive it's
an open source reusable component based
front-end library of JavaScript react is
a combination of HTML and JavaScript it
provides a reverse and opinionated way
to build modern applications
so let's see how we're going to create
the Instagram clone if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
let's open the Chrome
and I'm going to write Instagram
and this is how at the end of this
tutorial you will see your Instagram
clone okay
so
let's jump to the coding part open your
Visual Studio code
now let's create a react project
for that open your terminal
new terminal
you can also open your terminal by just
pressing Ctrl plus back type okay
here I am going to write a command to
create react project is
npx
create
react app now the folder name I'm going
to create as insta
Instagram clone
okay
it'll take a couple of minutes to
install all the files in libraries
so let's wait a minute
as you can see it's installing react
react Dom and react Scripts
so let's create a couple of minutes more
I'm sure at the end of this tutorial you
will love the output as you are going to
create a straight sample and fascinating
Instagram clue
okay let's wait a minute more
okay
now
okay it's taking a minute more that's
fine
we'll wait a minute more with this
after that
we're going to open half folder here
I'm going to create a react project
like in this Instagram clone I'm also
going to create the login page inside
the login page I'm also going to create
the sign up page when the user enters
they are the uid and password
they will be redirected to the home page
now
let's see how our application is looking
first we are going to go inside the
folder that we have created so I'm going
to write
Instagram
clone
now we are inside the Instagram clone
let's open our folder
where all the files are
so inside the C
users SLP
here is my folder let's open it
and see
now we'll open the terminal by just
clicking on control back tag
here I'm going to write
npm start to see whether our project is
working fine or not
so
let's wait and see the magic of react
react is a beautiful library of
JavaScript
okay you'll love the output in the end
I'm sure
let's see
so here it is the beautiful logo of
react
now coming back to visual studio code
let's install the material UI component
of react for that I am going to write a
command
let me just search here
you icon we need core
powder
open this npm
you want to open this one
but let's copy this command from here
it's copied coming back to a code let's
paste it enter
let's move to install all the files
okay fine let's sing
the other root folder
okay let's just see in this Json file
comes has been installed or not
okay
so there are so many packages here the
react is all dependencies react even to
your Dom your script
and
this score is not installed let me just
again
file them
okay
let's write npm
install
just a minute
yeah right
4.11.2 okay
so it will install automatically
here I'm going to open this app.js file
and as you can see just let's run this
file now npm start
let's say it's working fine or not
okay it's working completely fine
now coming back to our code
let's delete this logo we don't need
that
and let's delete this header
here we'll write H1
inside this H1 I'm going to write hello
from Simply learn
let's save it let's see what's the
output
isn't it looking cool
at the end you will see in complete
full-fledged Instagram clone it'll be
awesome let's see Instagram clone okay
fine
let's delete this one we need
to move forward
and
delete this one
because we don't need it
also I'm going to delete this file also
let's delete this image
okay
here
now I'm going to create component as
react is a component based Library here
I'm going to create different components
for this project
let's create a folder called compo
Nance
inside this components folder I'm going
to create a folder called
login
page
inside this login page I'm going to do
files as login
Dot login page dot Js
and
inside this login page only
let's create another file called login
page.css
now
instead let's just save it for now
okay
open your login page to us CSS not Js
port
react
or we can also write
import react
comma
here I am going to write
component
yeah
from react yes
I'm going to create a class of login
page
inside this login with extends I'm going
to use
state in this
component
let's create a Constructor
inside this let's write a prop
this let's write the keyword super
props
after this let's
this dot state
get the state inside this okay
now render
this function
to return
div
hello
world
let's save it
okay we need to export
export
to export each file you need to write
export
default
and then the file name
like login page let's close this one
let's save it
now
come back to app.js
here I'm going to write
login
login
page and as you can see
it automatically
imported the
login page from components login
okay
let's just save this one and see the
output
so
it's working fine
come back to our code
let's
this part
okay it's fine
let's import react
come after this
I'm going to
we're also going to use the credit
system here okay
code
four minutes
let's add upgrade here so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to make this screen
into three parts like three
to the left side three to the right side
and 6 to the middle
okay
no
so the screen is of 12
so I am going to use this 12 okay
let's
open our login page
and
pieces
and let's create a div now I'm going to
show you how to create the
in a screen
firstly I am going to take one div
inside this div I'm going to write
create
container
inside this grid container
to add one grid
item
of exercise
3.
okay
should not come under this it's
it's okay fine
yeah
here I am going to write some demo data
hello
to just let you know how the build
system works
now
to create one another let's
run
proper
hello
here I'm going to write from
and here I'm going to write
sampling
let's save it's showing an error
okay
let's find out the theater
everything is looking fine to me
let's see what's the issue here
okay
the grid is not defined okay it's fine
got to add the grid
okay I have added one command for the
grid yarn add material UI code
as this was not working
so I'm again going to add the material
UI
so let's see is it working fine now or
not
wait a couple of minutes to see
if it work that will be great
so let's just see the Instagram
login page for now let's just log out
from here
yeah
let's just open this
program yeah
this is how
I'm going to create the login page
so I have these pictures this one this
one and this one
so inside this
sign up page I'm also going to
create this signup page and this login
page okay
so it'll be very great if you'll
understand the process
the react is a very beautiful language I
love react
so if you love react
do subscribe to our Channel
post
amazing videos on a daily basis
so this is almost done
now I'm going to start this project
will not work within previous let's
see is it working or not
okay fine it's working
so as you can see it's saying okay let
me just delete this part
index.css let's delete this save it
coming back to our page
let's just save it
now
as you can see this is taking what this
piece which is
from here to here
okay
and this from is taking
space from here to here this Big Grid
and this simple learn is taking this
much space only three
so we have distributed this 363 inside
this 6 we are going to work
so coming back to the code
now we are going to create the login
page
so let's
hear
inside the login P dot GSS
JS let's add here yeah
inside this let's cut it and let's
create a Dev class
okay
inside this let's create another div
with this div I'm going to add one image
let's write the source of a DOT image
it's
insta
website against
image
okay this is not necessary
okay that's why it's not fetching we
have to import the image in the top
so let's write import
ant
just remember whatever you are writing
inside this
we have write it here also so
from
though this is inside the source
inside
the
folder dot okay
first it is inside the Instagram clone
then Source then inside that images
now inside that
I have added one image folder here I
have added some images they'll be
important and useful in this tutorial
okay
I'll give the link in the description
box for this project you can just get it
from there okay you'll get all the code
don't worry just see how everything
works okay
so here I'm going to write the code of
that image it was 9 3
6 4 6
okay it was seven five f
two six
Dot s3g
now let's save it and see the output
okay
it's saying we have packed compile with
one warning it's nothing image element
must have an old okay it's fine we can
do it in the CSS part
oh and boom you can see the output here
isn't it amazing we can just adjust
everything don't worry about that
but it's working
let's
you can add here like alter this image
hide width we can give
okay
now let's move forward
and add the width
let's give it width as
okay we can give the width as
and pixels let's write okay
450 would be fine
yeah let's
share
okay yeah
it's completely working fine
I wouldn't give the padding and all
for now
it's looking beautiful yeah
let's open that page with that
yeah it's already down let's again login
we'll face this login page okay yeah
it's up so let's make it
up only okay
yeah it's looking very beautiful
coming back to the code
after this let's create another div
let's inside this let's write
okay we have to make the Box
so let's
okay let's you can also add the image
here
yeah
now we need what let me just see once
okay we need one container inside the
menu we need that image
of Instagram okay fine it's easy
no big issues
okay
let's
right here again this
copy okay it's copy
and now let's paste it
so the name
so the name of this is not insta image
it's in
install logo
so what we are giving not right now
let's not go let's find if we can
okay we have to include this
inside here
okay
let's
copy this import
paste it here
and install logo
from images
75b 206a
yeah it's fine
let's add the name
insta
logo
dot PNG let's save it coming back to the
code it's showing an error can't resolve
it okay
let's Okay okay fine
I understood
so
it's not it's done it's insta
let's save it
now is it the same issue
it's the same issue
let's search for its time with DOT PNG
okay fine
now coming back to a code
we'll see
install logo dot PNG
okay fine everything
it's logo install
in just a minute
it's not this one
it's the
okay let me just find
lower things as here
let me just
there
let's write here
save it
yeah
it is working but the image quality is
very bad
moving ahead let's find the another logo
is there any low Bond size here
we can use this logo insta
let's try this one logo insta here
let's look
let's save it
let's see that yeah this is also working
fine
okay
go with this one only
hmm
the code
okay this one is fine we don't need this
width
this one
now let's give this first as a class
so we can also give the CSS properties
okay
so for that I'm going to give it a name
as login page
and Main
let's just save it
and inside this let's just delete this
one
this is this I'm dot yes no no
I'm going to write
login
page
inside this
I'm going to write display
then it should be
Flex
let's do it
coming back to the code let's see
okay it's fine
now again I'm going to write login
we need for log only
because it's coming
the next line let's give it to width
already given it over it so
cut it from there
let's
cases in different page
let's not mix it here
okay
let's see it's so coming very big
tit I guess
but no issues we will make it work
yeah
login page
over the Cs is not working okay
I forgot to add the CSS in this login
we also have two
at this CSS so I'm gonna import
Dot
login
page Dot
CSS let's save it now and see the magic
of CSS with
react
okay
this looks good
okay
back to the code
it's looking very slow
no issues evaluate a couple of seconds
because
okay it's not working
look it's
let's move forward
we can add new features inside this
so
we're going to add this logo here
what is coming
here
you want this
set there so let's
login
page
right
opponent
say this
is going to write
okay everything is looking good
height we're going to give eight
let's give it a height of three three
eighty as
it is as Instagram login page
[Music]
it's 350
border of that box which is one pixel
solid
let's give the exact color that
Instagram have
okay let's just save it now
see everything is attached
okay
let's just see
Instagram one is looking very big here
let's reduce this size
I'm going 155
let's see the warnings here
still compiling okay let's kill this
terminal
delete this one
inside this creating new terminal
let's write and then start and see
whether it is working
fine or not
let's just delete this
okay
it's coming inside that the only
let's see whether it is fetching the
login page
right
we have to add the
files here to fetch it okay
let's just copy this one
let's add it inside here
weather
first let's write them
please write component
here
paste
class name as login
s they were
login
right
let's just save it
here also
for this image let's give it the class
name
login
page
logo
save it now and see whether it is
working fine
okay let's hope it's working fine yeah
we have created one box and this is what
our Instagram logo
move it up
let's open our
terminal
so
it's fine
you don't need this one
one for the main
or one for the script container
and I'm going to add one
two
[Music]
three
you have created one div here
yeah it's fine
now it's looking
up
like here earlier it was looking down
now let's remove this
till now I'm sure you have
gotten the idea
for why we have taken this
okay let's make it like
systematic
yeah let's save it now
as you can see
in our app
and in Instagram
there is this one
margin on the top
so let's open our CSS
that I'm going to write margin
25 pixels let's save it
yeah
our app is also looking like the
Instagram login page
right
and then it started looking cool
right okay
let's make it as here as it is showing
inside there
yeah you have to give bad thing to this
Instagram
you have to create this also
so let's
give it some space here
let's
let's give it marching top to everything
so it should align C
uh inside the mean also
I'm going to give margin
25 pixels okay
now in this right
I'm going to give it a border which is
fine margin is fine
margin is what from Top we need
so
let's save it
this text line is
Center so our Instagram will
be inside this container which is Center
isn't it looking very similar to The
Original Part
now let's move forward
with the next step inside this container
I am going to create
these phone number and all okay
let's work on this container open your
login.jss
JS file
after this
let's create
a
div
inside this let's create another div
so
yeah
there are two divs
there's some space in between these in
this
so
it's fine
I'm going
to
open this
let's write
class of login
page
i g i n
written the wrong spelling
now let's write input text
inside the you have to use the play cell
you have to use that placeholder
like you also have to write these things
now
okay
let's write
similar input for password also
type
okay
it's not
type
which is
I'm asking
let's type
and the type of this is password
let's move forward
see
yeah
it's for username password we can just
make it
looks similar to the original one
with the help of
what CSS right
let's create a button
let's write sign
okay
let's just save it
you'll see one sign button yeah like
this
coming back to the code
let's write
let's
okay here we are
let's make it with CSS you have to OK a
class name
last name we are going to give
let's name it simple only login page
text
type this let's copy it from here
and let's paste it here
for button I'm
going to add another class
as login
button
let's just save it and see the magic
it's not showing let's see what's the
issue woman
oh there we are
added the CSS and why we are expecting
so many other things okay
first we are going to add the
for login text
and I'm going to write this tree
open page width
let's write 258
what is the exact same
height
which is 36 pixel same again
I've inspected these things so I'm
pretty sure of that
login
button
inside this let's give it a width
off
70 only
press the button should be
small
now let's see
yeah
okay we need to do some
changes here also well it's coming
outside of this container let's see
is we have added here inside the
container
and I have done few changes in the dev
now
as you can see
it's coming inside the container now
we're gonna give some space
so for that
let's give them some margin within your
piece dot CSS
and here
I'm going to give it a margin
of 5 pixels
okay
also I'm going to give it a border
because color is very dark there
I'm gonna change that solid
and
DB DB DPS
and this is looking good
and we have to create one more
which is
login
page
sign in
yeah
inside this let's give it a margin from
Top as
25 pixels let's save it
and see the changes yeah
so
now the color of this is looking exactly
like the
this one now coming back to the button
part
let's just
add
yeah
we'll be creative field added here
huh
as you can see here
it's not coming inside this because we
have
open this one in the
let's close this
let's first add the placeholder or let's
work on the button bar okay let's
first add the placeholder which is phone
number user name or email
so inside this text now
we have to add this
placeholder
after this I am going to add one
placeholder
which is going to tell us what's
comes inside this
number email
or
usually
okay
and inside here let's create another
placeholder
select this let's write password
save it
okay it's called
the email is coming
username
or
save it yeah
it's looking amazing
right
now coming back to the CSS file
let's give it a background
after the Border we are going to give it
a background color which is a little mix
of white
so I'm gonna write hash
f a f a f a let's save it
now it's a little bit
dark white okay
same as
this original one
yeah
moving forward
let's now
yeah
coming back to the code
let's
cut this one
let's write this
okay
we're going to give
padding left too
10 pixel
yeah this is coming fine
let's just
add one more which is
border radius here
which is 5 pixels is fine yeah
no
okay let's go
this button some height
after the height you're going to give it
border radius for five pixels
after that font weight
let's give the font weight bold
and then we will order for this
which is one pixel solid
and the color would be
okay let's see the color here
in the original one sky blue okay
bye
the sky blue color is zero three nine
five F six let's just save it
okay
it's coming
great
but let's just
because we need background color of this
as blue so
3956 yeah it's a little dark
okay
and the color of the button should be
White
so
you can just
let's see yeah it's coming beautifully
right
whenever we hide the ID password Here
yeah
okay
forward
let's
work on itself let's give
to minimize this
let's
add here body
we need to fetch this we need to add the
DOT
background
color
and the background color of this would
be
a little
you just see the original one
okay it's it's fine
okay
it's right only so we write FFA
yeah this one is great
okay
coming back to the right one
the center we're going to give it
back around
color which is white save it
now let's give this button a margin
margin from Top
because we need to add some space here
so we are going to give with the margin
of 5 pixels yeah this is the line now
now
let's see whether it is looking fine or
not
so
it's looking completely fine
so now we are going to split the screen
as power and all
so coming back to app.js
now we'll work on this part
this or
log in with Facebook in this everything
coming back to code
here
I am going to create one div
minimize this we can see the output
okay
let's create one Dev
inside the step I'm going to create one
div
modif
inside here we're going to write r
okay
looking cool I guess
save it okay with all is coming but we
need to add some CSS here
so we can just
make some space here so let's
write this class name as
login
space
divider
let's save it
okay
let's give this one also class name
as login
or
here also we need to get some
class name as
login
okay
now
you should also get this one last name
because
we need to I did this also in the CSS
I'm going to give it as
if
let's save it yeah
let's open our CSS file
let me just add the CSS here now
here I have added some CSS properties
you can see it
okay
so let's just save it and see
this is the r
now
let's work on this one
though
login with Facebook forget password okay
let's move
okay
so I have added one class of log in
Facebook here I am adding the image
where this is the keyword FB which is
can fetch in the import
login with Facebook and then another div
of class name login forget
or with password
and
here
till this FP
from the image folder
let's just save it and see
this is how it is looking we need to
shrink the size of this image
let's see the original one first okay
it's coming very small but in our case
it's coming very big so what we can do
is you can go to our CSS file and reduce
the size of this
login Facebook
so I have added here
margin top is let's add 10.
and see changes
nothing is here
so let's wait
okay let's not
d
here we can also
add the margin
right
so why can't we give the width here
it's right width
15 pixels
and let's see
yeah it's coming beautifully
right
now
coming to this password
you can make this as a hyperlink also
okay
but let's just give some styling to this
lock and see let's
a little less
okay let's just do it now
give it margin right
let's save it
all the image got lost
okay we just have to give
the
exact
number which is
5 pixel now
what it is saying it's saying this okay
okay
this can't be fixed from here
and it's again
okay we have Kevin
now it will be fine
yeah
yes it's looking good
now
will work on this
sign in and sign up button
let's just
go to our
project
there we are going to add
because we need to come out of that main
container
okay
so here I'm going to create one another
container
let's give it a class name of
login
page
okay
sign
up
options
okay
inside this let's create another div
class name
login
page
sign in
let's close this now here we are going
to write
don't have any account sign up
it's copied
and here we're going to paste that
right
now
we are going to create another div
let's give it a class name as
login
page
sign up
it is
the trade
on
sign
let's just save this one and see
our page
yeah it's coming
up
what we can do is
let's see what's the mistake here
it's coming inside the container but
it's not fetching inside this
okay
this one is fine
okay the sign up for 10 sign and it's
fine
this one is looking good
add it here yeah
now it's working fine
yeah
now what we can do is
you have to give this a little padding
so it comes under this
so coming back to
line up
the top base
you don't have an account sign up
you don't have any account sign up
and then oh we need to add
get app
let's first
from this now
get the app
let's minimize this this one also
refresh and it's coming perfectly fine
as I'm not going to add these data we
can do that
but I'm not going to do that
so
let's add some images like this one
here
for that
let's write here open your
clone get the app after that
I'm going to
create one another div
at this I'm going to add these images
okay
images source
door
let's close this one
to that again
image
source
Play Store
let's save it
okay
we have to
add the images imported
second
okay let's import this app store and
Play Store images
let's copy this one
copy
paste
that I'm going to write
App Store
and here I'm going to write Play Store
and the image name is
app
and this one is play
let's just save it
and see
okay
it's going very big we need to give it
the width also
let's
open our code
errone here we are going to give it some
width
let's give this one
136
pixels
yeah and let's copy this
yeah let's paste it and
yeah you can see the output
we have to make some padding and all
okay let's coming back to our code
let's give this one
sign up page oh let's
let's give it another
option
okay
so let this one only
let's fix this
let's skip this images
class name
as login page
this one
engines
yeah
now let's copy this
and
to this image
I'm going to paste this one
let's rename this option as
and here also
you are going to let's say we can see
it's still changes
get them
it's coming really
get the app yes
with this only so let's do something for
that
and here as
load
section
okay
let's
this one inside this div
this one
let's see it's still in the background
okay
let's just do one thing here
now it's looking fine yeah
so we need to give some padding here
let's give it some adding
Here Also let's just copy this property
only
paste it
save
now it's coming beautifully
there is some Gap here so let's
add this
watching motion
okay
edit this dwing part
okay this is a mistake
I thought it's not fetching the right
margin
it's not fetching the right margin
let's just
open the CSS
right here
top save it
watching is fine
okay we need to give some margin in
between the
container and get the app okay
so let's just see
in download section
say the download section we took gif
maximum betting
from here we have given some padding
buds
and things which fine so let's right
here
40
the login page option is also 40.
but it's not getting the space I want
so let's open this one again
it's a login option
login
with this one
Martin
top
fetching this one
okay it's fine it's not that big deal
so
login pages
done
so this is our login page
and this one
is Instagram login page
so
whose login page is looking more
beautiful guys
I understand
so let's move on to the home page
code
here inside this Source component
I'm going to create one folder
inside this component folder
holder
emat
of home
page
inside this home page component I am
going to create two files
let's name each of them as
om dot Js
and the other one is
Dot
CSS
yeah
save it
just
let things look fine now let's open
let's delete this
Delta
you have fetched the login video
everything looks good
let's create
la
Port reaction
yeah but I am importing component
okay
let's import the CSS file of this
old
home dot CSS
okay
let's create a class of home
now we'll see whether it is working or
Not by giving it up dummy text okay
let's maybe use our props again
keyword
it will fetch props
and this date will show us the
state of the program okay
now the main thing
friend of
whenever you are calling the
class you need to declare the render
function
so
let's let's give it
hello
from simpler
let's close this
again
need to export
for all
file name which is
home
let's save it and let's import it this
page inside the app.js
now
as you can see
portrait login page
now I'm going to import
home page
now
go home from
components
on each
okay
let's have it
see is this in the browser
errors
let's see
it's inside let's see the structure of
this
okay let's open this
source
component
wait okay
this folder is created let's
cut this one
paste it here
okay let's cut it now
now it should be working fine
let's cut these files
seven
now it will be fine
where it is showing
hello from simple learn right
coming back to our code
to the Instagram page let's
so this is how the Instagram page is
looking
what I'm going to do is
create one nav bar in the top
nav bar component which will
use these icons so we'll get plenty of
space to add the
uh stories in the vector and this box
part
then we'll follow the same let's
code
inside this component folder
another folder
does
Dot
now in this I'm going to create
JS and
the cssful
yeah
nav bar dot Js
2
CSS okay
now coming back to
let's do this
coming back to
let's
copy this
this
and paste it inside member.js
edit the
like nav bar
or GSS component
render
here
port
okay
never
let's save it let's bring an error let's
see what's it is
what should
okay everything
to invites just here
okay
it's right here as
member
so we can just
get what it is showing little
page take this
delete the whole thing we don't need
this
inside this I'm going to declare the
net bar
we faced in the single page
okay
let's set this div
okay let's
let's start now
let's
okay let's save it now
okay it's fine let's save it
let's create one more
components only
it's
main component
should go with bank
thank you
inside this main content will create
again two files
10th
Js
and mean content dot CSS yes
okay
now
again we'll go to home copy this text
going back to main content
let's delete this right
Main
content
let's delete this also from here
in 10th
and also this
yes
let's get
the plug here
content
inside the page everything fine
let's save it now
it's done
see
let's go to homepage
here call
this mean content
let's save it and in app.js
let's comment it down for a while
browser which
here
okay
now.js my body
page
board
save it now let's see the
YouTube
ever
and mean content okay
so
as you can see
that's these files okay
let's
component like a button mean component
now
inside this nav power.ts
let's
let's bar
create one there
is
r
okay let's
close it
now here
I'm going to use
grid
from Material UI
okay let's save it
okay
as you can see
a one component has been created
beautiful
let's create now
create hit this
let's give it a name
great
container
inside this container I'm going to call
for
it's
victim
and one is access
let's do
let's just copy this from here
well let's just save it
okay
let's
okay
let's see
good see
there is this issue that was coming
integrated
so I checked and the grid was not
properly installed in our system
now I have again called what this
command npm install
slash four
this F is denoted as forcefully
and again it is installing material UI
core
it will take a couple of minutes install
all the properties occurred
it's sweet
let's
analyze the
this will be resolved by
so we have to import the sales number
also
and these icons we can get it from the
material UI
icon and one company for the pictures
and one component for this one
go back to our code
it's still installing
shoes
let's just add some text
so you
get
now
and that is never only
let's import
logo
that we needed
logo
as you can see
you can see this
installed all the packages
cool
for that
let's add here
inside the images folder there is a
picture called
and stop
e m g
and let's
let's
create
this part
okay just cut this yep
okay let's first just see no whether it
is working or not
okay let's open this one
see you
in the editor
let's find out
so we have
finally compiled this program
successfully main problem was that
I was declaring it
should not come under
module so we have to import it like this
so
output of this program is like this
this is the component which is
the main goal okay the things
which will come under this as Story part
profile back upload that part in here
recitation part
the Never
declare the Instagram logo
okay inside this
let's add it here only in the center
go ahead and the image we have already
imported the
image on the top
let's write
install logo
with this one
save it
showing the big Instagram logo we don't
need that we can
change it in The Styling bar
happen
let's
give it a width
let's write
pixels
save it
okay
so I can add The Styling CSS
bar
logo
okay
now let's see it's coming very beautiful
but let's just delete this part
space
yeah
this looks good
back to this
let's
all right
input
text
search
please
holder is what you know guys
let me
it
just come on that box
with the implementation of this search
box yes
yes okay
let's create
here
come
inside
three three six seven eight
minutes
let's go and train you know
Style
set this I'm going to add
display
which should be
Flex
okay
it's this
and let her import some
image
everyone fine
other ways
let's give it a word for 25 pixels
save it
copy this one
fine
yeah let's
go back
so one is home one is
Siege
other one was
that trying button
now
as you can see
it comes the grid of the screen is 12.
so we have used 11. now I am going to
create a new grid here
let's give it size of
one
and that would be empty
okay
now let's import the images on the top
again
that
is
and move that is
pasted
both
yeah
let's
find
also the name of the images
save it
I can't switch this 3.3 G
let's see
let's see
now let's check
okay
it's coming beautifully
so
yeah
it had to get Instagram icons we can
also write these names but it will take
much space so
as you have noticed there is one
file
portion also
which is round and inside that
is a picture
what we can do
that let's go to a code
let's see
okay
yeah
let's give
class name
does
bar
search
bar
yeah
save it
it's
into this
everything which looks fine to me
let's create this screen
no
this is the time we can
add the
logo the
page like this one okay
come back to the code
what we can do is we can import
Avatar
UI core let's say this is
which is this one
head
yeah now
you have to declare this inside this
so what we can do is
star source of the image
DB
what this image
the
let's first
image
image
Style
okay
and inside the style
um
Max height
okay
Max High
let's try it
sign us
25 pixels
then
with
let's give it does
now it's looking good
excited again
five pixels
just close this one
as it is showing you letters because we
have been imported the
each
so let's write DP for
the name of the image
save this one
still showing two errors let's
read them
parts
inside this network.js
what's together
up let's just
put one more terminal
let's kill this one
okay
set the network only I understood
but let's just run this one
right
this
problem so what we can do is
actually okay this
this weekend remove only
with the probing problem was without
CC can do
not found
the
function
which is
good
so looking
picture
let's see
let's see what it's
so whenever we find any error just copy
that and paste that inside the
Chrome
on stack Overflow you'll find plenty of
answers of that
so our main issue is with the avatar
maybe it's not installed or what
words
at this point
okay
let's read something
similar here
okay
let's find out
again it's the same issue
with that
it's working fine
yeah
it's just coming a little
in that properties no it shows that
let's give a little more sense to it
and let's see now
here on this one is looking
okay
yeah
coming back to the code
now
let's style them properly
image I'm going to give the class name
as
limit
or we don't need
this
image
okay
yeah
let's just copy this
and paste it here
here
and here let's save it now and see the
module
yeah it's coming beautifully now right
everything is aligned
and you can see the nav bar very
beautifully aligned
is not looking very good this main
content let's move that first
okay
yeah
let's remove this one let's
now you see this is how the nav bar is
looking isn't it beautiful
right
forward
coming back to
God
it's fine I have added the CSS
properties you
can
and
I'll I'll upload all the code in the
description box you can just copy that
from here
okay
let's
move ahead
now let's close this
is never
main content will
be fine first thing first what we are
going to do is
I'm going to import grid here
sure
let's remove this
and let's
add the proper location of the grid
fine
let's right here
grid
container
inside the script container
I'm going to add two grids
is
size them as
to
six first
okay let's
close
let's right here
great
item
six
the main thing what we're going to do is
inside this
Okay so
space
let's create here
okay
create one
and put it here also let's complete this
structure okay
this is looking final
now
where we can just
add the size here
it's fine everything is look good now
start booking this
so let's
add here
on dev
and take this
let's
add
let's first here you can
yeah
in the components part
let's create two folders or components
State this bar
okay
and then status bar again we are going
to
create
to files Js
CS
status bar
CSS yeah
right now
we are going to create one another
component
which is main page
in in this main page folder
folder
it's deleted
okay okay fine yeah
okay let's create
in page
and select this main page let's
go again
base dot Js
Main
the dot CSS okay
that's the
page
and the status page which will come up
because data should come
okay
let's just
capitalize this
okay let's save it
yeah everything's look fine now
let's import these files inside this
first we'll import the
status bar
um
status bar
again we are going to import this
page
from
you can
yeah let's save it
now
if you can see here
declare anything inside this
switching it
now let's just
do last part
with the class name
as me
attend
container
let's save it
to status
I'm going to import
okay let me just cut this part
copy it from
the place
cut this one
if
it's
beat this
just put the
react
component
from
you react
yeah
let's just save it
in trial
it is important this is a status bar
so it is bar dot CSS
seven
eight
Theta Square
cylinder function
say also
default
if the status bar
let's just
we don't need this
status bar
okay
let's just copy it from here and set
this
let's paste it
stood some
motions here
mean page
okay
let's save it
here also
and page
and
when it comes to exporting the file
save it
set the tab
yeah
now I will see the output
so
this is our nav bar this is the status
bar this is the space that we are giving
to this
status bar and this is the space which
is the main page which
yeah coming back to the code
in class name
of status
bar
where all the stories will come okay
right
so let's create another div
ided
speed status
okay let's close this
R again
foreign
let's save it
on top
ICS
but
status
meters
straight source
status image will clear the image
casting
status
status
yeah okay yeah
let's just copy this few times
it's just
foreign
status image
from
methods
while food
okay it was
zero
yeah
isn't it looking amazing yeah we have to
align it but
you can see the status bar let's add
more
status let's copy this
and add two three more here
save it now let's see
yeah
this is looking really very good okay
you have to align it into the center
okay
yeah
let's
come back to the code
let's see
now what you have to do is you have to
make this container that status part
into the center of this mean page
you can do it right
okay fine
I'm going to add the status or the
pictures here you have to add the
container into the center on your own if
you need any help you can just comment
it down I'll help you out okay but now
you have to do some things
so that you can learn about this
technology more
now we'll work on this main page okay
now
let's create a folder here in the
components
as post where we'll add the pictures
inside this again I am going to create
two files
JS and the CSS for The Styling yeah
os.css okay fine
now what we'll do is
let's copy this
and paste it inside this yeah
and
here
we are going to give the right path
post
let's get the lastly post and then
what we are exporting here is post yeah
save it
now
let's import this into the main page
okay
let's show you an adder let's see
what's the
in there
okay
let me put we will imported it
the reason it's showing this error
post
from
post
and then post
let's save it now
let's say this
okay this is
import this file
maybe let's cut it from here yeah
paste it here now save it let's save
this also
everything looks fine now yeah
now
how we can check this is working or not
is
you have to add here
hello
save it
this would be fine yeah it should be
fine
now we can add the pictures here
okay
let's remove this through map yeah
let's start working on this component
let's read this hello
inside this first div let's create
class here
and let's see matters
until
yeah
now
let's leave it as
you have to remove it after that but
let's just now
the better Clarity of this program
to
read this okay
okay I'm creating another div
in like this you have to create file
okay
let's
do it
yeah
okay
let's delete this
next thing
we get three like this
yeah
okay
it's fine
one component we have to create there
okay fine
inside this first header
what I'm going to do is
let's see the Instagram component
okay
so there is one image
and the username okay
let's
okay
inside this tab let's create
a
post
and Taylor
okay
after that
inside the another container
let's right here of that because we need
to add the
Loop
okay so let's get a class name
of post
images
and let's write the source which is
the
that I will
send
okay
yeah
now one thing more we have to add is
that you have to add the username as we
discussed
you have to add the username so I'm
gonna write post
username
and then inside this
okay it's not necessary but let's write
the username
okay
in this component
I'm going to write the
image okay
so the reference like this
names and all okay fine let's move
forward
imported
let's save it
we use it okay you can just
change it after a while it's not an
issue
now
let's move to the image component let's
inside this div I'm going to create the
image
source of the image would be
post image
let's add the width here
width is
that's right 600
thanks
and pixels
let's just save it
you have to add the English for now but
it's fine
okay
now let's see the
import the image
Dot
post
image
from
images
photos I'm using this picture so many
times
okay
let's save it now it should be
completely fine
yeah
so with this
we have created
are simple
for beginners
Instagram clone
so with this we have reached the end of
this video make sure to like and share
it
let me just show you in the last how the
login page was looking
okay let's just
show this
save it
you will find the code in the
description box don't worry if you have
any questions you can just ping me down
and I will also add this part in the
code
in those sections part
no worries you will be good to go thank
you so much for watching this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here